if you want to hear about how M night
Shyamalan planted clues about split
class way back when he made unbreakable
in the year 2000 then stick around to
the end of this video
[Music]
welcome aboard the special episode of
things you missed and yes I already know
what you're thinking no cz you can't
cover unbreakable it's not a horror
movie
okay hold on don't tell me that the
scene of the is Ambani family's house
isn't terrifying and second I'm doing
this because I'm covering the entire
series which means splits a horror movie
and also I just want to do unbreakable
and it's my channel I can do what I want
and if you haven't seen split you'll
probably want to have seen that as well
as I'm briefing so with that being said
let's take a look at unbreakable the
first scene shows the birth of Elijah
price and we first see the child's who
would later become known as mr. glass
through the reflection of a glass mirror
this is a common theme in unbreakable
were introduced to age thirteen Elijah
through the reflection of the glass
television screen and were introduced to
adults Elijah through the reflection of
the glass in one of his pieces at the
Art Gallery
when David meets Elijah for the first
time not only are we looking through a
glass window but the characters are
framed in a box just like a comic book
we're by appointment only I got a card
from this store
the reason for these choices is that
Elijah sees himself is nothing more than
a fragile broken piece of glass and his
entire purpose throughout the film is to
find his real place in the world and
discover why he is the way he is in the
next scene were introduced to the
protagonist David Dunn note the
alliteration of his name like many other
superheroes
Clark Kent Peter Parker Bruce Banner and
several others one of the first moments
of David being on-screen hasn't looking
at a child in the seat in front of it
who is upside down like the recurring
theme of glass inversion is also
something that seen time and time again
in unbreakable and to understand it it's
important to understand the connection
between the film's two central
characters David and Elijah are
opposites in every way but one one is
invincible and the other is as fragile
as they come one gets sick very easily
the other is never sick one is
physically gifted the other has a hard
time even getting around David as
light-skinned Elijah has dark skin David
is very reserved well Elijah is quite
outgoing and of course David is the hero
while Elijah is the villain so when all
is right with the world the camera is
upright as it should be but when
disaster is about to strike when
something bad is about to happen the
camera is inverted in relation to its
subject the upside down girl precedes
the train crash David's son Joseph
watches TV upside down before learning
of the crash
Elijah lays eyes on the comic book that
first gives him the idea that he's
supposed to be a supervillain and it's
upside down
Elijah falls down the stairs and sees
the man with the gun get away with a
numbered perspective and Joseph sees his
dad lift an impossible amount of weight
from upside down which later leads him
to pull a gun on his father there's also
an inversion reference hidden in the
credits David's wife is named Audrey
done but there's a separate credit for
the actress who played that age 20
Audrey before her and David were married
where she's referred to as Audrey and
versa
finally Elisha discovers the comic that
helps him find out what David's
kryptonite is and that's upside down as
and speaking of that kryptonite that one
weakness that David has David tells
Kelly the woman on the train but he's
thinking about getting into a male
synchronized-swimming which is funny
because we later find out that his
weaknesses water director M night
Shyamalan also used the idea of water as
a weakness in his next film with signs
there's also a connection to his
previous film The Sixth Sense and that
Bruce Willis is the star of both movies
David's wife also mentions that her
favorite song is soft and wet by the
artist formerly known as Prince another
word for soft is a week and David
becomes weaker whenever he gets wyatt's
kelly also asked David if he likes
football and he says not really we later
find out this is a lie David was a huge
football star and he still works as a
security guard at his former school
Stadium so that he can continue to be
around the game Kelly is going to
Philadelphia to meet with the cornerback
from Temple University who later appears
in the movie he's in the park playing
football with a bunch of kids one of
which is David's son one last thing on
the train and this isn't confirmed but
I've got a hunch that this could be
Kevin Wendel from his father who was
said to have disappeared on a train when
Kevin was young and never came back
but you never met the beast because he
doesn't reside with the rest of you
because he resides in the train yard as
the story goes because Kevin's dad left
on a train but the fact is you and
Patricia have never met the Beast
alright it looks like this is my stuff
all right always good to be back so
where were we
after the accident and Joseph has seen
watching television starts with this
dull commercial featuring a
skateboarding banana then he flips the
channel to Jerry Springer and the
Powerpuff Girls which is a 90s superhero
cartoon and then an episode of I am
weasel another 90s cartoon this episode
is about a smart banana that comes to
life and it's actually a really funny
episode I'm not entirely sure why there
are two separate references to a living
sentient banana perhaps an early
foreshadowing of the Horde whose
defining color is yellow or perhaps
something to do with banana splits could
be something there I should also
probably explain the color scheme for
anyone who hasn't seen my glass trailer
analysis David is almost always wearing
green from his shirt in scene 2 to his
iconic rain poncho Elijah can mostly be
found wearing purple and the present
from his mother is wrapped in purple it
even goes right down to Elijah's purple
walled office and David's kitchen with
the green cabinets which looks beautiful
when complemented by the orange accents
after David defeats the orange man oh
man we could talk about color theory all
day with this movie but let's switch
back to wherever we were right the TV
the news of the train wreck comes in on
channel 4 news whose logo resembles the
logo of the Marvel superhero group the
Fantastic Four
so David ends up being the only survivor
of the train crash and after the
memorial received a note from Elijah
which leads him to discover that he's
never actually been sick then as we
previously mentioned the flashback to
Elijah's childhood where he receives the
gift from his mother a comic book titles
the battle with jaguaro jaguaro is a
beast like antagonist wearing yellow and
a reference to the beast from splits
jaguaro is going up against a superhero
wearing green obviously a reference to
David
they say this one has a surprise ending
yes it does
Elijah tries to sell the original
artwork as an adult calling it a classic
depiction of good versus evil
however when he learns that the buyer
wants to get this as a present for his
kid Elijah is outraged and I love that
little moment where Elijah's explaining
that this is an art gallery not a toy
store and then he asked the prospective
buyer do you see any Teletubbies in here
and the guy actually looks like oh my
god there's no Teletubbies in here but
anyway after her David meets Elijah and
thinks that he's a scam artist which is
interesting in itself considering
David's innate ability to sense evil
David goes home and reads the newspaper
article about the train crash of east
rail 177 the photo of the rack is
credited to Kevin Ladson and he's
actually the prop master of the movie in
the article the name of the
Transportation Secretary is Kia
Dickerson who's also on the art
department of unbreakable part of the
article mentions that the trains had
just had an engine check prior to
leaving the station an early hint that
foul play was involved on the right
column there's an article about raising
money to build prisons who has the
number of inmates expected in the next
decade perhaps some of the criminals
caught by David Dunn will inhabit these
prisons then David takes a look back at
the newspaper highlights from his
football career one of the articles is
written by Scott Murphy San Juans
assistant art director and the
photographer Jim Fang is reference to
James Fang another assistant art
director here's another reason I love
this movie always good to see the
Brewers losing the article about David's
car crash in college is written by
Robert Holtzman yet another assistant
set decorator he's interrupted from
reliving his glory days when his wife
comes knocking on his door and asking if
David has been with anyone since they
started having problems I'm prepared for
any answer and it won't affect me she's
lying the answer won't affect me she's
lying it won't affect me either way
she's lying
told you the next day at work Elijah
shows up and we're introduced to David's
ability to sense bad people in the crowd
when he predicts that a man wearing
camouflage is carrying a silver weapon
with a black grip and that he will step
out of line which he does
Elijah sets out to see if David's
prediction is correct he steps out of
his car which is completely covered in
padding in order to pursue the gun but
on the stairs to the subway he has a bad
fall and the shattering of his glass
cane represents his frailty I already
talked about these scenes let's move on
to the next dating scene a single mother
and red bumps into him and he hears the
sounds of child abuse roll it like the
spirit of Philadelphia maybe just maybe
this kid is a young Kevin Wendell crumb
from splits but it might be impossible
to know for sure it is a different
actress playing the mom but it has been
15 years so it's just possible that they
weren't able to get that woman who was
an extra and set back to play well I
don't know let me know what your
thoughts on that are in the comments
though then there's a cameo from the
director and that Shama on himself David
has called away from work because his
son Joseph has an injury at school when
he gets in a fight with two kids who we
later find out our Potter and some other
guy it was another guy they were messing
with this Chinese girl in the dressing
room you may remember a Potter is the
cousin of the cornerback from Temple
he's Potter's cousin he's starting
cornerback at Temple University and then
we've got Joseph Gunn seen now
supposedly this was inspired by an
incident that really happened to
Superman after George Reeves where a
child confronted him with a gun and
asked to shoot him to prove that
Superman was invincible and Reeves
convinced him to put the gun down by
telling him that someone might be
injured by the ricochet I don't know if
that story is true but either way it
could have been used as an inspiration
for the unbreakable scene finally David
revisits the wrecked train cars and
remembers the incident he and Audrey
went through in college where he was
actually completely unharmed in the car
accident he decides to become a
vigilante and saves the two girls from
the orange man in the newspaper article
that comes out the next day we find out
that those girls were tied up like that
for
the author of the article is Nicola
Marcela of course in our department
assistant Scott Murphy the sports writer
from before also has something to say
about the breakup of farmland in this
other article so this man has many
passions it seems and the farmland stuff
could be another hint towards signs
being shy Milan's next film finally
David visits Elijah's art gallery
showing and meets his mother see the
villains eyes and larger than the other
characters they insinuate a slightly
skewed perspective on how they see the
world these are just a couple of final
clues towards the reveal that's about to
happen in a couple minutes Elijah has
always seen the world from a skewed
perspective through those big eyes of
his but what's truly amazing is her next
comments but he says there's always two
kinds there's the soldier villain who
fights the hero with his hands and then
there's the real threat that brilliant
and evil archenemy who fights the hero
with his mind Shyamalan was planning to
bring the horde from split into the
equation from the very beginning in fact
he would later reveal that the Horde was
at one point supposed to be a part of
unbreakable but he cut the character and
saved him for split because the movie
was getting too crowded I've got one
more thing you missed but first remember
to subscribe to seize these worlds from
new Horrors every week next week I'm
gonna be doing a things you missed and
split and you definitely don't want to
miss out on that so make sure your death
Bell notifications are the final freeze
frame of the movie states that Elijah
price is in an institution for the
criminally insane why would it say that
if this is not a true story and
Shyamalan wasn't planning on having
glass take place in that institution 19
years later I'll see you in the next one
assuming we both survive
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]